1960 la france fait face à la crise du
logement
la forte croissance démographique de
l'après-guerre l'exode rural et
l'arrivée des rapatriés d'afrique du
nord entraîne en effet une véritable
pénurie d'appartements l'expansion
économique bat son plein il faut
construire construire construire à
toulouse comme ailleurs on se penche sur
la question
le maire socialiste de l'époque louis
bazerque décide alors de créer une zup
zone à urbaniser en priorité dans un
quartier dont le nom deviendra célèbre
le mirail en 1962 c'est le projet
proposé par l'équipe d'architectes
candilis jozic route qui est retenue
pour l'époque un projet révolutionnaire
qui prévoyait un maximum de voies
piétonnes le respect des parcs existants
et le mélange des lieux d'habitation
avec les lieux de travail
le mirail devait alors accueillir cent
mille personnes réparties en trois
quartiers la faculté la reynerie et
bellefontaine
en fait tout le projet reposait sur un
double pari un diminuer au maximum les
déplacements des habitants en réunissant
sur place logement services et travail
de réussir à recréer la communication
entre les gens grâce notamment aux voies
piétonnes aux coursives et aux
équipements sociaux malheureusement
aujourd'hui en 1982 ce double pari est
un échec
le mirail même s'il reste un exemple
dans les écoles d'architecturé est
devenue une cité dortoir de 40000
habitants où la misère progresse de jour
en jour
je vis avec eux les français par mois
d'indemnités journalières par jour par
jour par jour par jour ce qui fait bien
le bonheur de vis assez bien pour moi
comment on peut vivre avec une telle
somme aujourd'hui au logis si l'on vient
commenter
ban sera pas une bille techno mondiale
et
mais la misère au mirail si vous êtes
sur le terrain c'est un homme de terrain
la misère c'est quoi qu'elle cache la
misère baisser la misère de façon
traditionnelle c'est-à-dire sait les
difficultés financières d'abord et donc
des problèmes alimentaires donc du
problème d'insalubrité vers les
appartements qui a acquis sont pourtant
dans les immeubles récents et puis c'est
aussi la misère morale à la misère
culturelle qui est particulièrement qui
est particulièrement forte et pour
couvre la plupart des habitants du
mirail sont des déracinés qui viennent
d'algérie ou de l'ariège le problème est
le même
personne ne peut se retrouver dans le
béton
oh
avant
quant à la communication elle ne reste
qu'un doux rêve chacun pour soi et dieu
pour tous ces débats de contact avec les
autres le temps ça fait trois ans vous
habituer bah oui mais ça va bonjour
bonsoir mais chacun veut voir personne
je les aime une autre et vous disiez
tout à l'heure que vous vouliez partir
oui et encore cette femme est poli
certains immeubles sont plus que sal
alors à qui la faute s'il est vrai que
les habitants ont une part de
responsabilité dans cet état de fait les
véritables responsables restent les
trois sociétés dash-l m
le fils public le fils des chalets et la
société languedocienne leur politique
est simple c'est celle de la carotte et
du bâton
ceux qui payent régulièrement leur loyer
et sont mis dans des immeubles bien
entretenu les autres sont entassés dans
les bâtiments délabrés comme celui de
varèse
vous allez à côté c'est impeccable ce
propre il n'y a pas de ça c'est comme ça
mais vous venez ici il ya des gens ils
disent que c'est la faute des habitants
de l'immeuble
autre problème qui prend des proportions
considérables au mirail le racisme en
effet si le quartier au début on était
habitée que par une population française
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
comme partout la population française et
migre vers la maison individuelle alors
que les populations immigrées sont
concentrés dans certains immeubles
créant ainsi de véritables ghettos le
racisme au mirail existe et sous la
forme la plus primaire je ne suis allé
chercher des places avec des jeunes dont
je m'occupe principalement des maigret
est refusé
catégoriquement même si la place était
et est disponible parce que c est un
émigré les seuls à échapper un peu à ce
phénomène ce sont les jeunes beaucoup
ont grandi dans ce quartier et au fil
des années ils ont appris à respecter la
différence d'autrui et à des copains
étrangers tu connais pas de france est
tout les copains sont étrangers sur la
nationalité l'algérie au maroc les
fruits d'une eau tous
on entre plus facilement en
communication avec les jeunes qu'avec
les parents quoi si je puis dire et quoi
ça tient
ça tient qu'à un peu de méfiance enfin
je crois je crois que bon
on dit pas comment aurait on réagit pas
comme mangent pas comme je crois que ça
vient de là le racisme le chômage
l'alcool le divorce la misère la
prostitution la délinquance la peur tel
est le vrai visage d'une cité dortoir en
1982 plus personne ne parle tout le
monde a peur peur de quoi
c'est ce que nous verrons demain soir